en este vídeo vamos a ver cómo conectar
el controlador del motor l 298 a nuestra
base y también veremos cómo colocar los
cables de los motores en nuestro
controlador lo primero que vamos a hacer
es poner la tapa que es parte de la
lámpara adhesiva queremos asegurarnos
que quepa y no lastima el circuito del
controlador ni los cables ya que la tapa
va a quedar algo ajustada así que
debemos asegurarnos que todo quede
centrado ya que lo centramos vamos a
tomar un lápiz o una pluma o cualquier
cosa que tengamos para marcar los bordes
en mi caso los lápices mecánicos me
funcionan muy bien para esto ya que
podemos marcar muy bien estos bordes
esto nos va a permitir pegar el
controlador justo en el centro colocamos
suficiente silicón caliente en la tapa y
después ponemos el controlador encima
teniendo cuidado de alinear los bordes
que marcamos con los bordes del mismo
controlador
es muy importante alinearlo bien porque
si queda más hacia un lado o hacia el
otro pues la etapa no va a quedar bien
cuando la coloquemos
va a tomar algo de tiempo para que el
silicón caliente se enfríe ya que es
bastante cantidad es mucha masa térmica
que le lleva algo de tiempo enfriarse
incluso podemos sentir cómo se va
calentando la base al sostenerla una vez
que ya se enfrío el silicón caliente y
nuestro controlador se encuentra bien
seguro en su lugar nos vamos a asegurar
que la tapa sigue quedando bien
alrededor de los cables y el controlador
recuerden que tenemos muchas conexiones
adentro del recipiente y quizá tengamos
que rotarla para lograr que quede esta
es la forma en la que debe quedar el
controlador y los cables ahora vamos a
recortar los cables del motor ya que
vamos a conectarlos a las partes que les
corresponden en el controlador tanto los
de este lado como los de este otro lado
así deben quedar
ahora vamos a pelar unos 3 milímetros de
cada cable en ambos lados una vez que
los tengamos listos ya podremos
colocarlos en donde corresponden es
importante no quitar demasiado aislante
de los cables unos 3 milímetros o quizá
un poquito más ya que si quitamos mucho
aislante en la parte positiva podría
tocar la parte negativa y los motores no
van a funcionar si tienen un
cortocircuito vamos a aflojar nuestros
tornillos en la montura de conexión de
nuestro controlador
colocamos nuestros cables y volvemos a
cerrar nuestros tornillos para mantener
estos cables en su lugar
vean que no tenemos ningún cable
expuesto lo que sobresale tiene aislante
hacemos lo mismo con los cables de este
otro lado y si algún cable queda algo
largo simplemente lo hacemos a un lado y
con esto terminamos